boa tarde
eles também haviam bom eu tinha 14 anos
de idade quando entrou um vídeo cassete
primeira vez lá em casa eu morava no
interior de montenegro porque é uma
coisa engraçada dizer que montenegro já
é inferior à do ano anterior do interior
mas era isso
morava no interior do interior não
necessitava mais então da sessão da
tarde ou das poucas exceções no bravo
civita nópolis que existe até hoje na
cidade
eu comecei a ver toneladas de filme e
pensei vou fazer cinema
naquela época isso era uma decisão
completamente estúpida porque a
faculdade de cinema só no centro do país
e encarar uma usp fazer um curso na usp
era algo muito assustador para o
interior do rio grande do sul o que de
fato era gás continua sendo assustador e
além disso a produção nacional passava
por um momento de quase morte na
produção de longas na pior crise
provavelmente da história do cinema
brasileiro
por essas e por outras que eu demorei um
pouquinho pra começar a trabalhar com
cinema na metade dos anos 2000 fiz os
meus primeiros curtas metragens mas eu
queria fazer alguma relevância artística
de fato o filme que fosse bem acabado o
fundo fosse bem realizado e que fosse
acima passasse um pouco dos aditivos que
o mesmo estava nos meus trabalhos
anteriores de ser esforçado de ser
simpático 2011 tive uma ideia incrível
as nossas ideias normalmente são
incríveis aquelas que se apossam de ti e
exigem realizá los
cassandra o nome dessa idéia seria um
curta metragem de terror voltado pra
sutilezas terror psicológico
rodado em preto e branco com uma
protagonista muda
um pouco desse umas falas no decorrer da
da história mas parecia ser uma idéia
infalível e ela tinha em mim um efeito
muito poderoso eu precisava fazer aquela
história é como se aquilo fosse por
alguns demónios um passado não muito
distante de tudo pra dar certo para que
eu continuasse assim tudo pra dar certo
eu pensei pontos
vamos cuidar dos detalhes orçamento para
fazer o filme técnica equipamento assim
fazer um com resultado final e
especialmente as pessoas fariam porque
por mais que a gente precisa de dinheiro
de tecnologia para fazer cinema
são pessoas que fazem cinema e eu acho
que sem as diferentes visões de um grupo
de pessoas é praticamente impossível
fazer um filme tão procas andra esse
curta eu escolher equipe muito a dele
chamei ou conclamei por assim dizer
colaboradores de outros filmes velhos
amigos
chamei novos talentos que eu tinha recém
conhecido que já tinham ganhado espaço
no meu coração e me armei uma
grandessíssima cara de pau pra chegar em
profissionais consagrados que não
conhecia pessoalmente dizer e aí quer
fazer um filme de terror pânico 3 meses
a equipe montada a gente começou a rodar
quatro dias de filmagem muito tranqüilos
e um alvoroço na equipe desde quando a
gente viu as primeiras cenas se criou
uma expectativa enorme inclusive foi
comentada pelos próprios veteranos pelos
próprios caras mais experientes vai
viajar muito com esse filme em cima
ganhar muito prêmio é só uma coisa que
eu ouvi que me dá uma esperança muito
grande
os ânimos exaltaram quando a gente fez
uma campanha de profanarem financiamento
coletivo muito exitosa ea equipe ficou
em êxtase e vendo e sentindo o filme com
intensidade máxima pronto em 2013
seleção no festival de gramado para a
mostra gaúcha prêmio de melhor
fotografia na mostra gaúcha de gramado e
o futuro que parecia brilhante
a produção fez uma tabelinha no google
docs
mas continuo escrevendo filme e eu
ficava olhando com aquela tabela
sonhando assim mais que receber a
marcação de selecionar e daí começou o
inverno
durante um ano a gente não foi
selecionado para mais nada
o festival grande festival pequeno
tradicional desconhecido e ninguém
queria gente começou a se perguntar o
que estava acontecendo e eu pau qual a
protagonista do meu filme mudo sem saber
o que dizer que não entendia o que
estava rolando também não quis fosse
novidade os meus curtas anteriores
tiveram mais ou menos o mesmo problema
talvez até pior
só que logo com esse esse que eu estava
fazendo com tanta paixão tanta gente
tinha fazendo conta da paixão que estava
acontecendo que nem festivais de filmes
de terror queriam o cassandra durante
uma festa num dia que recebi duas
negativas de festivais
mesmo nesse dia eu decidi que eu ia
abandonar não só a cassandra como
abandonar o cinema em abandonar qualquer
coisa relacionada com cinema e eu jurei
que eu nunca mais e assistir um filme de
novo na minha vida a sério essas paixões
é uma coisa complicada com amor virar
ódio é namoro vir até de casamento gay
inferno e eu
apaixonado por cinema ficava me
perguntando por que que o cinema não lhe
atribui esse amor que eu tenho por ele
um ano assim aconteceu uma coisa muito
bizarra ou uma sucessão de coisas
bizarras pessoas que tinham ouvido falar
do filme começaram a entrar em contato
comigo e dizer olha que fazer um
festival e no interior fazer um festival
na minha faculdade nada escreve que o
filme eu animado por pessoas dentro da
equipe que não queriam desistido do
curta
inscrevi tem uma nova chance pro filme e
deu caçando explodiu em questão de seis
meses a gente começou a empilhar uma
série de seleções foi para o exterior
foi pra outros estados do brasil e
começou a ganhar prêmio ganhou o prêmio
de melhor direção de arte prêmio de
melhor música ganhou o prêmio de melhor
filme e o meu primeiro prêmio de melhor
diretor e o segundo prêmio de melhor
diretor
quando as nossas expectativas não
funciona a gente começa a se perguntar o
que foi que aconteceu
procurar critérios nas artes o
especialmente o festival de cinema há
uma coisa muito difícil mas eu comecei a
notar um padrão muito curioso e que
ficou muito claro determinado momento
esses festivais que aguardam com horta
prémio melhor curta metragem
eles estavam no seu início vários deles
estavam na primeira edição de fotos
online de brasília festival de cinema de
três passos
a mostra monstro já parei alguns estavam
na segunda terceira se encerra de caxias
do sul do rio de janeiro até falta santo
anjo
isso quer dizer o seguinte em 2011
quando tive a idéia de fazer o cassandra
nenhum desses festivais existe ainda o
filme foi feito um filme foi feito foi
realizado terminado e alguns festivais
ainda não existiam ou seja eu precisei
esperar que pessoas são apaixonados por
cinema quanto ao avançado mais
realizassem os seus próprios sonhos para
que meu filme não ficasse enterrado em
camadas de limbo e daí eu volto para
montenegro
eu tinha um amigo de infância d
zezinho pedro pedrinho o pedrinho era um
filho lá é pedrinho é uma pessoa
inteligente para divertir mas era um
mentiroso compulsivo aproveitador enfim
a moral e mas tem uma coisa com ele era
meu amigo e quando terminou a oitava
série
ele decidiu estudar em outra cidade e
faz amigos e eu conhecer os amigos dele
e mais tarde quando me mudei do interior
da região metropolitana esses amigos e
apresentaram pessoas que se interessavam
por cinema e com essas pessoas que se
interessavam por cinema eu fiz nos
primeiros filmes e com várias dessas
pessoas eu continuei trabalhando até
hoje são algumas delas colaboradores do
cassandra e portanto se não fosse
pedrinho
eu talvez não tivesse cumprido um sonho
de adolescência
talvez eu não estivesse aqui agora mas
uma decisão que o pedrinho tomou para a
vida dele mudou radicalmente a minha
afetou a minha vida inteiramente o que
me faz pensar que por mais que a gente
tente ser do nosso destino mais
resistente é o controle das coisas
a nossa vida é diretamente influenciada
pela decisão dos outros
essas pessoas malucas e maravilhosas
resolveram fazer os seus festivais em
cidades do interior dentro das
universidade e com recurso que ela tinha
uma mão eu não sabia que eu precisava
dela eu queria fazer o melhor filme que
era capaz de fazer mas se não fosse
esses outras pessoas apaixonadas
abnegados eu também não teria conseguido
chegar em lugar nenhum
até a vida de um filme é marcada pelas
decisões dos outros é um pouco a
libertadores bastante assustador com
normalmente as coisas libertador ação
pensar que a nossa vida depende muito
muito mais do que a gente imagina a
decisão dos outros
porém é mais assustador pensar o oposto
se é verdade que os outros fazem e
definem afetam a nossa vida que nós
definimos o que nós fazemos é definir a
vida dos outros também não só a família
não só nossos amores nossos amigos
nossos contatos nossos contatos de
trabalho mas talvez em níveis muito
maiores e muito mais profundos que a
gente consegue imaginar fazer a arte de
fazer cinema e talvez toda atividade
humana seja assim mas fazer cinema é
tentar ligar as pessoas
a gente tenta construir pontes em velas
e talvez essas fontes sejam mais longas
e mais sólidas do que a gente é capaz de
imaginar o que que é o de que vocês
estamos decidindo agora obrigado